olá pessoal e mostrou se que o baralho e
não só pessoal sim do poder descartar
escolhida
eu pensei num cubo streck llamadas mil e
600 mil e 800 de defesa e fãs têm de
perceber não é
hoje estamos aqui pra gravar algo que
nunca gravar é lembrança daquela
publicação o bumbo aquela que já tinha
procurado no instagram os membros não
supostamente esse contato descobre tudo
aquilo que vocês fazem ou já fizeram e
vamos ver quem vai responder hoje já que
entre 1º de tumor já vi ser muito
sinistro aí já mandaram que a mensagem
que eu faça um comigo vão se juntar à
antónio ramos arrecadamos o hisbolá a
camisa vou enviar ainda não respondeu à
mensagem
mesmo com tudo isso não foi quando eu da
foto já passaram alguns minutos já
passaram 34 minutos e ainda não
respondeu nem para pensar oh oh oh
respondeu olha o bumbo sabe o que o
antônio já brincou com o tabuleiro ouija
e não terminou hoje o [ __ ] outra mesa
menina ana carla
o bumbum sabiá grau que tiveram cuidado
já passaram três meses como é que ela
vai terminar essas coisas todas só
sabendo antônio lisboa não sei que eu
não saí eu ainda podia saber que o
youtube mas há muito por onde andam por
aí vai mandar o professor viu assim
então que o português o jogo
eu entendo assim não eu vou vender
enquanto isso vou evocar a minha carta
respondeu que nunca jogou
não sou maluco como tu trair quem não
sou maluco como tu
vamos ver agora na internet que só tem
de voltar a jogar e brilhar ao todo o
velho preceito
sério o que foi uma pena eu te dizer que
eu tenho que sair nós nem sequer usar as
regras do tabuleiro ouija agora já vamos
ganhar tabuleiro ouija e ver se é viável
ou não
o jogo está aqui já não china está muito
tempo apagará as luzes todas a muitos
ditadores não sou maluco com muito mais
vigor é na internet que só tem de voltar
a ajudar e impedir o trabalho parceiro
o cartão é isso que vamos fazer eu ponho
aqui o modelo e depois de tê lo ea não
misturo não vamos sim acho que vou
começar eu tenho que fazer 18 é preciso
primeiro ficar ali estavam
porque quer agora existe alguma tirar
paranormal aqui neste estúdio de mexer
não to juro mesmo juro está entendido
existe alguma atividade paranormal aqui
neste estúdio apce legislativo foi então
não terei o dedo de 22 livro quem está
ou tentado falar comigo eu vou deixar
ela que single escolhido outras vezes
não
eu fui perguntar ao bom quem é que está
a tentar comunicar conosco que manifesta
algum senão um senhor com chamas de seu
espírito e na boca e se não resulta como
de chamas mas o bumbum sabe que é alguém
vindo de muito longe perguntar o que o
amigo miguel monteiro
eu sou o teu nome para com isso
insira e uma testada a chegar contínuo
eu sabe eu sair não sai não sair não sai
não sai
conosco eu não sei mas vamos disputar o
grupo c também porque expõe o bota nosso
estado [ __ ] aí para uma área que é
pior que o que falar mas não consigo
juro desmo como se chama pessoa que está
a tentar contactar conosco te
perguntarem espanhol contato caso
espanhol eu quando fui quando perguntado
se o espanhol não chegou nada rápido
quanto eu não sei falar espanhol como o
da itália vão olhar vocês tentaram um
tabuleiro ou e ram e nunca longe no rio
tabuleiro ouija como se chama lá persona
e que está aí tentando contactar conosco
não é manter a força ao euro
não sou eu disse o que eu disse que eu
sou ilp agora foi conseguir brincar de
alzira em campo eu disse que é de longe
eu vou responder um miguel não sabe
primeira mulher não sabe o nome mesmo
quando o que faço agora o que faço agora
eu vou poder continuar a jogar só
começar do jogo sabe tabuleiro ouija
podemos ir do jogo leve foi assim eu não
sou eu estou cheio não sou eu juro aqui
porque não sou eu que acho eu não disse
nada não disse nada está em branco o que
é isso que vai ficar em dúvida porque em
tabuleiro ouija poderemos sair do ego a
hora
por favor não jogou assim o uruguai
respondeu e nem respondeu eu não sou eu
e sim supostamente usados cias
[Música]
o bom que sabe que é tarde demais
olha para a câmera de vigilância espero
até qualquer merda já não sinto
dificuldade jogando não porque eu
comprei câmara ontem não foi cumprido e
lembrou que eu nem disse nada a ninguém
olha para a câmera de vigilância olha
que ele espera envolver com a professora
comprou esta câmera de vigilância ontem
ela chegou ontem onde está lá mostrar
outra vez do iphone eu consegui ver a
câmera ou cair só para só não sei só
torcedor sem deus aqui e quero ter medo
olhei comido temos aqui só está com ele
e eu consigo o cheiro tipo na câmara
aqui agora calma eu disse pra nós
olharmos para a câmera
vejam y a câmera observar nos viu em
movimento qualquer
acho que ali na porta o botafoto tudo
está resolvido não espera aí eu disse
pra nós jogamos pra câmera eu estou
muito sinistro ainda possibilita e mora
em franco manda a cena é que seu uso
aqui está o e sinistro puty o tuco tuco
[Música]
tudo escuro porque estou aqui obviamente
[ __ ] está mais puto daí o iphone da
manhã o iphone [ __ ] apavorar quadro
nó não vou embora daqui não vou abrir o
cofre
eu não vou abrir
segundo o qual nenhuma o que vocês acham
assista aqui é real ou não isso aqui
caiu por minha causa porque eu sei que é
uma pancada mexe só edição de vídeo é
que eu vou ver o que aconteceu esta
porta mas que a porta fez barulho fez
agora eu não sei se foi quando a zona de
restauração porque o exposto a mente tem
um restaurante food isso não podem
existir aí você estiver aí que está a
dar muito medo caiu
não não eu sei que não existe
bom pessoal vamos ficar por aqui e digam
que é como fazer um tabuleiro ouija e
dilma e se acham que isso é real ou não
comente e deixe vossa opinião e queimá
lá eu acho que não existe em nossa
opinião pessoal já sabe quanto eu estou
aqui favorito fiquem bem e até a próxima
o papa